也不可能帮你平这个账啊，
我是单亲妈妈快五年了，
然后独自抚养的孩子嘛，
他就是家里人帮着抚养的孩子，
然后因为去年跟朋友就合伙搞了一个小店，
然后就亏了点钱，
然后现在负在大概有10个，
然后我们家里的话就普通家庭，
然后现在谈了一个男朋友，
谈了半年了，
然后他人也挺好的，
对我儿子也挺好的，
然后现在就是因为我的负债嘛，
然后她可能这几个月帮我支持一下，
然后他也负债，
相当于我俩现在一共加起来有18个，
然后家里面不敢说，
然后我名下的话就只有一个十几万的代步的车，
然后房子是我父母的，
我父母是准备留给我儿子了，
那时候等我儿子成年了，
现在就不知道怎么解决那个钱，
我的这个钱一半是因为合伙开那个店亏了，
利息很高的，
然后就越滚越多，
然后他的钱我跟他认识的时候，
他就已经有在，
然后就差不多4个多左右嘛，
到后面在一起了以后，
然后可能平时。
用呀，
或者怎么样啊，
然后加起来我俩一共18个，
现在就是不知道应该怎么办，
家里本来自己是欠10个，
我男朋友，
这个男朋友说是帮你帮忙，
可能是生活上，
他给我生活费啊，
您用呀，
那他是出了一部分钱呢，
本来我认识他的时候，
我发现的时候他就有4个，
然后他说是跟我在一起后滚到了8个读，
那你现在想要龙飞姐帮你分析的问题是啥呀，
其实他人挺好的，
就是说如果不告诉父母的情况下，
我俩应该怎样把这个钱给评上，
因为现在真是是花掉了，
对不起，
你这个问题真的是让龙梅姐，
梅姐也不可能帮你平这个账啊，
不是不知道怎么办，
家里面不敢说，
家里就就我一个父母年上年纪了，
知道吧，
其实我以前的生活过的，
因为我带着儿子嘛，
我儿子很优秀，
我为了培养他，
其实我过得也很艰辛，
然后我是因为觉得父母年纪大了，
儿子又那么优秀，
我就想着自己跟朋友一起搞个店啊，
多挣点钱，
然后也没有想到去年年这个行情也不好。
就滚到了现在这个样子，
你主要是你主要每天的时间是要带孩子嘛，
是吗？
嗯，
我是边上边边带孩子，
一直都是这样，
我不知当讲不当讲啊，
然后换个男朋友吧，
就说你俩在一起凑一块儿是吧，
赚钱能力都不行，
你俩凑一欠债你也别叫，
别连累人家了，
你就换个男朋友啊，
经济条件好一点的，
你别图帅，
别图年轻，
别图和谐，
啥也别图，
你就图他经济条件好一点是吧的，
能够去承担你的这些呃债务，
且人家也不把这个事儿当成个事儿，
除了对吧，
除了说换个男朋友，
你还有一呃可选择的呢，
让你俩这智商凑一块再去挣钱的话，
我怕窟窿越滚越大，
对不起啊，
怎么会？
姐没有恶意啊，
我就说让你俩可凑一块再去挣钱的话，
我怕赔的越来越多，
亏得越来越多，
他想的是让我去跟我父母说把房子过户给我，
然后让我去把房子做抵押，
然后去贷了，
然后他的工资一个月一个W，
这样嘛，
然后多一点，
然后说三五年就把银行的给还了，
这个。
房子我知道是，
嗯，
我父母要给我儿子的，
我也不可能去动我儿子的，
因为我儿子很优秀，
不要这么搞，
那个房子在你父母名下，
对于你们整个家庭来说的话，
它是最后一道防线，
我说句难听点的话，
假设你骗你爸妈，
你把这房子过户到你名下，
然后抵押了，
抵押出来，
到时候你背负着是各种欠款，
对不对？
相当于说你拿你自己的父母的房子去抵押了，
然后把你的男朋友解套了，
然后你就被完全套进去了，
你被完全套进去了之后，
假设你俩将来感情又不好，
假设你俩将来生意又没有做起来，
窟窿越来越大，
他是没有损失的，
他完全可以完美的解套了就走了，
因为他名下已经不欠债了呀，
但是你到时候就被套死了，
肯定不能这么干的，
我觉得我的解题思路是没问题的，
你就承认你俩卧龙凤雏承认你俩都对吧，
都不是什么挣钱的料，
你换人呗，
我就是其实跟他其他事业又处的很好，
他跟我儿子也处的很好，
就现在唯一的问题就是说有这个负债，
然后他想因为他们家嗯，
兄弟姊妹多嘛，
然后我们这边的话就我一个嘛，
然后就说想着让我去跟我姨妈呀。
真的那气千万不要，
姑娘，
你不觉得这个男的很自私吗？
他表面上看上去帮你解决问题，
但是解决了吗？
我就问你，
结果在这摆着呢，
你的问题没解决对不对？
没错吧，
你本来是欠10万块钱对不对？
现在考倒好了，
听来听去好像这18万都该你来解决，
你不觉得这是有问题的吗？
哎，
你不觉得这个逻辑，
这个逻辑漏洞，
罗菲姐，
我再捋一遍啊，
本来你就欠10万块钱是吧？
你身上就10万块钱的担子，
你有没有发现，
你现在谈了一场恋爱之后，
哎，
欠18万了，
而且这个男的里外里都是想你来解决这18万，
哎，
问题出在哪了呢？
问题出在这个男的始终也没有帮你解决问题，
还给你窟窿越捅越大了呀，
而且他现在是让你一个人来堵窟窿吗？
嗯，
我昨天晚上就是想了一晚上，
我也觉得是这样，
但是这10万就是我不知道我的这个我就不知道该怎么解决了，
弟弟就是我们舅舅他们家的儿子就给我说，
然我给我父母坦白了，
因为我父母他们毕竟就只有我一个嘛，
大不了把这个窟窿给填了，
以后就不去搞这些了，
嗯，
这个思路是可以要填，
只能填你名下的债务啊。
不要卖房子啊，
不要抵押了，
不要想了再停了，
嗯，
就还有一个问题就是嗯，
我现在征信应该是花掉了就快黑掉的那种，
如果这种情况的话，
对我儿子以后升学会不会有影响啊，
9年义务教育没有任何影响，
将来考大学有没有影响，
将来可能政策也会有变动，
我说难听点的话，
现在出生率这么低是吧，
对吧，
人手都不够用，
还卡这个卡那个干啥呢？
不用考虑那么多啊。
啊，
那就这样啊，
龙飞姐真的啊，
不是说恶意的去干嘛干嘛的，
就是龙飞姐就觉得如果不是做买卖这块料，
如果账都算不明白，
我说的账算不明白，
是人生的账都算不明白，
就像刚才啊，
龙菲姐帮你一算账，
你就明白是咋回事儿了，
就这男的出现在你的生活里之后，
让你的窟窿越捅越大，
而且这男的话里话外的意思都是让你来赌这个窟窿，
让你们家出钱来堵这个窟窿，
对不对？
那这一算账，
我跟你说，
这个账你要是没算明白的话，
你要是做生意。
你要是再做什么大买卖，
那我可真是担心哦，
只能是窟窿越捅越大，
你，
你就别做生意了，
老老实实的对吧，
老老实实上个班，
挣几千块钱够花，
然后呢，
爹妈再给你孩子留点，
孩子以后有房子是吧？
你就上上个班，
挣点钱够你们娘俩花，
这挺好，
这日子啊。